[Music]
what is up everybody it's banner Mak
here for anime uproar and in this video
we are going to be talking about
Tamura shigaraki one of the main
villains in the my hero academia series
and the acting leader of the notorious
league of villains now some say that
it's weird that for me
villains are some of the most
interesting characters in this series
but I think that Shigure Aki is a great
example of an interesting mysterious and
eccentric villain character that we all
want to learn more about in this video
we will discuss everything we know about
shigaraki
and his work and we will also talk about
some of the unsolved mysteries regarding
his hidden past and true intentions I
will share my thoughts on some of these
mysteries and I invite you to tell me
what you think in the comments below now
there will be manga spoilers in this
video so proceed with caution
and now if you are ready to go be sure
to disintegrate that like button and if
you're new to the channel don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell Tomodachi guy Rocky's real name is
10 kashira and if that last name rings a
bell it is because he is actually the
grandson of Nana she Munna Almighty
predecessor and the seventh user of the
one-for-all quark in chapter 95 of the
manga we learned that Nana's husband was
killed in action as a hero and this may
not realize how dangerous the life of a
professional hero can be in order to
protect her son from being a target for
villains trying to get revenge on her
she gave him up for adoption to a foster
family and she instructed all might and
gran torino not to contact her son under
any circumstances so as not to expose
him to danger after this we are not sure
what happens to she Rocky's father or to
him until she go rocky makes his
appearance as a villain in the series
shigaraki is directly mentored to become
a villain by the mastermind behind the
league of villains and formerly the most
powerful criminal in japan a man known
as all for one which is his villain name
and it's also the name of his quirk but
more about him later in his super
villain costume shigaraki has 14
disembodied hands
are holding different parts of his body
including a hand that covers his face
shigaraki called the hand that covers
his face
father and he has a strange and
obsessive attachment to it even when he
is out of his villain costume and just
wearing normal clothes he has been seen
bringing the hand with him in his pocket
and talking to it and this just makes
him an even more mysterious character
since we know almost nothing about his
father or what really happened to his
father and we know very little about why
she got rocky the mental state is so
unstable but more on that in a little
bit now let's get to ask work previously
his quirk was referred to as
disintegration because of its ability to
disintegrate objects and people but it
is now confirmed in the anime that the
name of shigaraki squirt is decayed so
the name of his quirk is decay its type
is emitter and it works on contact with
his quirk shigaraki has the power to
literally destroy anything he lays his
hands on including hard objects and
human bodies the destruction activates
automatically whenever he touches
something with all five on his fingers
so in order to touch anything that he
doesn't want to destroy shigaraki has to
make sure that he touches it with only a
part of his hand aside from his quirk he
is also known to be very fast and
intelligent shigaraki has strong stats
over all according to the my hero
academia character book although he
scores only a 2 out of 5 in power and
cooperativeness he scores a perfect 5
out of 5 in speed technique and
intelligence which is really impressive
for a young villain who still has a lot
of room to grow now in terms of his
mental state shigaraki is often seen as
being disturbed unstable and childish
aside from his obsessive attachment to
the hand he calls father he is prone to
throwing temper tantrums he is cruel and
ruthless and he appears to look at the
world as if it was a game he refers to
his plans as gameplay he calls all like
the final boss and when he loses a fight
as was the case at the usj he says game
over now what I really want to know and
what fascinates me is how did she go
naki become this way in the first place
what happened to him in his childhood we
know that he has scar
on his face from when he was still very
young and in chapter 88 we learned that
he was mistreated as a child while he
was suffering as a child no hero came to
rescue him the symbol of peace almighty
didn't come to his rescue and it was
actually all for one the mastermind
behind the league of villains who
finally rescued shigaraki and became his
mentor in fact the mentor relationship
between Almighty and Deku in many ways
mirrors the relationship between all for
one and shigaraki except where death who
wants to become the greatest hero Shiva
rocky wants to become the greatest
villain in case you didn't notice we do
actually get a preview of all for one in
the second opening for the second season
of the anime at least a preview of his
frame after becoming a villain shigaraki
also becomes obsessed with killing all
mine because all might is the symbol of
peace in the world of my hero academia
shigaraki believes that if he can kill
all life then the values of modern
society will die with him and the
villains will be free to shape society
in the way that suits them shigaraki
wants to expose the values and ideas of
justice in modern society as false and
he thinks that the best way to do this
is to erode public trust and heroes and
especially in all might as the most
powerful and popular hero in fact in
chapter 92 of the manga
all-4-one tells all like that shigaraki
has been working on eroding public trust
and heroes for some time the question is
what happened to Shiva rocky in his
childhood to make him the way he is and
also what made him hate all might so
much we only get a very brief
explanation of Shiga Rocky's background
as I mentioned we know that naina
Shimura is his grandmother but Nana gave
up her son Shigure Rocky's father to a
foster home and we don't know anything
about what happens to him after that
some sources claim that she Rocky's
father is dead but looking through the
manga I didn't see any actual evidence
to back this up if I miss something in
there let me know down in the comment
now if we look at the manga panels that
include flashbacks to shigga Rocky's
childhood in these brief glimpses
shigaraki looks like he is being held
prisoner in some sort of filthy room
before
all-4-one comes to save him so
traumatic incident he suffered likely
did not happen outside where everyone
could see we know that while Shigure Aki
was suffering no hero came to save him
but if something happened to a small
child outside in the open even if no
heroes came to save him surely the
police would have it is much more likely
that she Gaddafi was being abused by
whoever was his guardian as a child and
this was being done behind closed doors
if his father really died when she got
rocky was young it could be foster
parents that are mistreating him and if
this was the case it would make sense
for shigaraki to blame the justice
system for allowing him to be adopted by
abusive people he would certainly feel
that the heroes appear to be too busy
making big public appearances to come
and find him when he needed their help
but of course they would not have been
able to find him because the abuse was
being conducted behind closed doors on
the other hand perhaps his father didn't
die and the father was the one abusing
him maybe she got Aki accidentally
killed his own father while defending
himself from the abuse with his quirk
and now he feels guilty about it and
projects that guilt onto the hand that
covers his face maybe his father would
grab his face in the exact same way when
he was a child or something along those
lines we can't know for sure at this
point but something traumatic like that
would definitely explain his unstable
mental state but then we have the
question of why does Shigure Aki hate
all might so much other than the fact
that all might is the symbol of a
society that shigaraki beliefs failed
him there could be a family connection
as well we know that all mice quark one
for all dates back to two brothers the
older brother is all for one she got his
mentor and the mastermind behind the
league of villains and he had a quirk
that allowed him to steal quirks from
other people and either use them himself
or transferred those quirks to others
all-4-one transferred a quirk that
stockpiles power onto his younger
brother because the brother was believed
to not have a quirk but in fact the
brother did have a hidden quirk which
allowed him to transfer quirks from
himself onto someone else this is how
the quirk one-for-all was created it is
a combination of the
filing power quirk that the older
brother transferred to the younger
brother and the Henan quirk that the
younger brother already had that gave
him the ability to pass his quark on to
someone else the older brother all-4-one
eventually became the most powerful
villain and Japan and the younger
brother who was the first user of one
for all decided that he would stand
against his brother's evil plan he was
not able to defeat all for one on his
own but he transferred his quark to the
next generation until finally all might
the eighth user of one for all was able
to defeat all for one but what if this
term next generation isn't just
referring to transferring the quark to a
random new person what if it means
transferring it to literally the next
generation of your own family such as
your own child what if one for all was
transferred from generation to
generation within the shimmer of family
all the way up until Nana Shinhwa
decided to give her son into foster care
and transfer the quark to torsion or
yagi aka all might instead we know that
this is possible because all for one is
very old since he appears have stolen a
quark that allows him to live longer
along with many other quirks and if this
is the case then chigan Aki and his
father would have an additional reason
to hate all might he received the quark
that was supposed to be passed on to
them so in a way he stole the Shimura
family's birthright away from them if
this was the case it would explain a few
other things as well
for instance doesn't a younger brother
the first user of one for all remind you
of anyone we know
this similarity could be a coincidence
but maybe it isn't maybe it's a clue
that she got aki is directly related to
the original user of one for all also
this would explain why all for one takes
such a keen interest in Shigure aki out
of all people all for one continues to
believe in and encourage shigaraki
throughout the series despite shigaraki
has many failures and in chapter 89 we
find out that all for one even plans to
find a new quark for shigaraki that
would suit his personality all for one
second she got Aki everything is for
your sake all for one
even ends up getting arrested because he
wanted to make sure that she got a key
and the other villains could escape in
chapter 91 so he stays behind to keep
all my busy it really doesn't seem like
she got a key is just another random
recruit to all for one it's almost as if
they were family and if she got a key is
directly descended from all four ones
brother through Nana and the other
Shenmue degeneration the two of them
would in fact be family now this is just
a theory of course since we don't have
enough evidence about shigaraki
background yet but I would love to hear
what you guys think and if you have any
theories of your own what we do know is
that she got rocky continues to grow and
evolve as a villain as the series goes
on just as all-4-one intended him to we
see that she karate learns from other
villains including from staying who
teaches him that the most successful
villains are those who have a Creed and
overhaul who teaches him that villains
must always have a career plan in mind
the forced retirement of all might who
was the symbol of peace combined with
the erosion of trust and heroes among
the general populace caused by the
league of villains and other villains
like stain are sure to make shigaraki an
even greater threat in the future and
that is it tomoyasu shiga rocky and his
quirk explained personally I think she
got rocky is a very interesting
character I am really intrigued by his
mysterious past and I can't wait to
learn more about him if you enjoyed this
video and you want to see more money or
academia videos be sure to Texas smash
that like button and if you're new to
the channel don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell feel free
to tell me your thoughts and theories in
the comments below and also let me know
what types of videos you want to see
next as always thank you so much for
watching and until next time see a space
cowboys
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]